[Music]
you think you know how the world works
you think that this material universe is
all there is but what if I told you the
reality you know is one of many
this doesn't make any sense
not everything has to felt estranged
throwing the mystic Artes we harness
energy and shape reality the Avengers
protect the world from physical dangers
we safeguarded against more mystical
threats
who died protecting this one mystery
doctor
mr. doctor it's strange maybe pool as a
judge
dr. strange your work saved the lives of
thousands what if I told you that
reality is a lot of many strange is
incredibly arrogant brilliant sort of
extraordinary and his need to control
faiths to control destiny and in
particular death as brought in to the
height of his professionals in Euro
surgeon he has a car crash and he loses
the use of his hands and she spends all
his money having operations to have his
hands put back together and they don't
work he has quite a journey as his life
starts to fall apart do you spend what
he's lost pennies on a ticket and goes
to Nepal
he's searching for a cure for his hands
and the issues that he's having my
character introduces him to this
different very mystical world he finds
the ancient one who is a sorcerer
supreme you wonder what I see in your
future possibility
brings out this spiritual dimension
which he never knew was possible and he
soon realizes that potential is someone
who could help on a grander scale that
he'd ever imagined actually existed
we're excited about the villains in this
film these are people who become seduced
by what they find on the other side as
well they're interested in spilling the
barriers between these dimensions which
would annihilate our entire universe I
can't do this who is no other way
there's a lot of real-world live action
in this film has a lot of drama a lot of
comedy but there's also the most
extraordinary fantastical adventure I
think it's gonna be a great cinematic
Rider
[Music]
the Doctor Strange story is a great cast
of characters chief among them is Carl
immortal well it certainly is the intro
to dr. strange entering this universe
Mauro is very close with the ancient one
played by Tilda Swinton she deals in
magic in real proper in art magic
together both the ancient one and Mauro
they sort of begin his training there
are other ways to save lives
so much you don't know
we're excited about villains in this
film we call them the zealots these are
people who become seduced by what they
find on the other side Casillas is part
of this temple if the majority is
looking for the truth here he's looking
over there for the truth he is
interested in spilling the barriers
between these dimensions
dr. strange you think you know how the
world works what if I told you the
reality you know is one of many
this doesn't make any sense
not everything does not everything has
to
[Music]
for the mystic arts we harness energy
and shape reality
we travel great distances in an instant
I get from here to there how did you
become a doctor studying practice
yesterday
there's a strength to him but is he
ready
the devil which paths you travel
downstream stronger men than you have
but away
a debt and pay
the diet echo as well
I can't do this there is no other way
I've spent so many years
through time
looking for you
but what's this fine launcher it's the
Wi-Fi password we're not savages
[Music]
[Music]
Stephen strange let I offer you some
advice
forget everything that you think you
know
[Music]
your man looking at the world through a
keyhole
you've spent your life trying to widen
it
your work saved the 9000
what if I told you that reality is one
of many
I don't believe in fairytales about
chakras or energy or the power of belief
you wonder what I see in your future
possibility
why are you doing this
so much you don't know
you
you
[Music]
vote
[Music]